Welcome everybody. So first thing I'm going to do is kick off today with partner program.
The intent here is give you a clear understanding of the requirements and the timelines that are
coming up for that. Again, here's a picture of me maybe 15 years ago if I haven't met you in person
and then Vanessa as well. If we want to go to the next slide, I'll go straight into this.
So again, what I'm going to review is the partner program. It's going to be a high-level
overview. I'll call out some of the changes that have happened around data in AI summit that we
announced to make sure that we're all on the same understanding of what's required. Good news is
some of the requirements have been pulled back. So I think this is going to help everybody progress
a little bit as we hit that mid-year point. So first off, I'm going to speak to the tiers.
Because I think this is important that everybody understands up front how we're structured. So
at the very top, we've got our Platinum tiers. Now for everybody in here, it's important to
understand that the Platinum tier is really designated as an invite only for our global
partners. Again, so this is deep investment, deep relationships. This sits at the very top,
covering multiple regions. Again, think GSIs, think global. Now as we go one step lower in that,
we have gold. Now this is where we have our most strategic delivery partners with a mature
Databricks practice. Everybody in this tier is a proven track record of multiple use cases and go
to market efforts with Databricks. This one is open to every partner in our ecosystem who's going
to be able to climb and attain this. And again, within this, it has the highest set of benefit
offerings at a program level. One step below, we have silver. Now silver for us is where we have
Databricks practices that are growing. Their bench is building. They have a trained certified team,
successful implementations, and all of our core products and offerings. But again, it's also
very important to remember that these tiers are really based on a point in time. And with our
program only really being maybe two to three years old at this point, you see a lot of partners,
especially in certain regions who are still moving through these gears. Now if we go down,
we're at the bronze. Now bronze is probably where we have the most partners today. And it really is
a case of again, a point in time on where you're at in your journey. This is the entry point for
partners coming in. But at data and AI, what we actually launched is we no longer have a requirement
here to be silvers for specializations. Now what that means, as soon as you enter and you come
into bronze, you can start to utilize those benefits to start attaining specializations
to differentiate in this space. So again, mileage may vary here, right? You may have some partners
who have just entered in, you might have some that are right on the cusp of going into silver.
And again, this is broadly how we present and position our partners internally and externally,
is through this tier program. I'm going to go to the next slide, because the next natural question
here is, you know, how do I get, how do I get into those tiers? So we have it based on a partner
value score system. Now it's important to understand what you have to do in order to pick up these
points that'll let you progress through those tiers, pick up additional benefits. So we've
kind of split up into three categories. Now the first one is going to be customer impact. Now
this follows the sales motion. I like to think of this as the performance metrics from our partners.
First one we have here is going to be sourced MRR. This is where a partner has initiated
use cases. And then the MRR of that use case as it goes live will help you earn points. We also
have implemented use cases based on MRR and then unique active customers. Now the great news here
is all three of these can double up, right? If you have an opportunity to use case that you register
in source, you implement that. That would actually give you points both for source implemented and
a unique active customer. So again, you've got a chance to hit on these multiple times. The next
category is readiness and enablement. And again, I think, think capability, think capacity. This is
where we want to give you points where you have certified individuals and active badges. We want
to make sure that you can position data bricks appropriately, drive your go to market, but then
also have the capacity to execute as well. Now all the way over to the right, this is where we
have go to market collaboration. Because it's important that we have a metric to look at success.
Now the best way for us to do that today is through customer stories and CSAT, right? Customer
survey results that come back on use cases where you've implemented. So again, all of this is pulled
together to give you a point total. If you want to go to the next slide, I'll show how that is applied.
So we look here, we have it calibrated across the different regions. So if we look at the absolute
gold standard in a mayor, we're at 95, LATAM 70, AMIA 80, APJ 70, right? So there's a calibration
that takes place based on the maturity of that market and where we're at in progressing. Now,
above and beyond the partner value scores here, we do have two additional requirements that sit
outside of that scoring system. The first one is delivery experts. So globally, if you have attained
your PVS score that gets you into the silver category, you'll also need five delivery experts
and four champions. And again, that's not calibrated for regions. That's a global requirement that
sits on top of that PVS scoring. For gold, same structure except the delivery expert requirement
is going to be 20 and the champions will be 10. Now, again, just remember, this sits outside of
that today. So again, the partner value score again is going to be a collection of those
scoring systems that we just went through. Additional requirements are going to sit on top
of that, not calibrated for regions. It's going to be set globally. Okay, next slide, please.
Now, one of the reasons we're going through this today is because we're actually coming up on our
mid-year. So what we do in the middle of our fiscal year, that is when we look to do promotions.
So you've got a full four quarters, one year, and where the first half of the year allows you to ramp
up. Come the end of this month, we're going to check where everybody sits. Anybody who has now
moved up to silver from bronze and gold from silver, we're going to make sure that we get you
promotions mid-year so you can start marketing yourself as such, receive those benefits, and then
we can use that internally as well to make sure that our sales teams are aware of the changes.
Now, that means for everybody in there, and we're going to go through the analytics dashboard soon,
make sure you know where you're at and how close you are and any gaps because you might have a
couple things that might be low hanging fruit for us to get submitted that can move you across
that line between now and the end of the month. Now, the other question that typically comes up
is when do demotions occur? What if I've slipped back somehow? We don't look at that until the end
of the year. So again, we do promotions twice a year. Demotions or any drops happen once a year,
and that'll be at the end of our fiscal year once we go into February. So again, a timely conversation,
it's a good chance for everybody to review their dashboard, understand where they're at,
to make sure they're either on pace or if they even have an opportunity to get to that promotion
coming up at the end of the month. All right. I think, Venos, I think now actually,
I'm going to hand this back to you and you can do the deep dive into that.
Awesome. Great. Thank you. If we have questions to tackle so far, you let us know, Jose, if that's
okay? Not I will carry on. Awesome. So in this segment, I'm going to deep dive into the partner
value score and then wrap up with the analytics dashboard overview so that you can see where
your company's journey is today and give you some tips so that you can continue to manage that and
build a plan around it for promotions or maintain your current year as well. So before diving into
that, I have two slides covering basic terms that are important as we go through the deep dive. So
the first slide is covering the registration versus use case. So think about the use case as the
entry door to start collaborating with our sales teams in the opportunities. As the opportunity
progresses and it's validated by our AEs as a consumption producing opportunity, then it will
be converted by the AE in a use case, which ultimately gives you recognition for MRR.
One key thing to call out in this slide is that when you know the AE, it could become optional
that you register the opportunity. The AE might go directly into creating the use case for you,
which as I mentioned, once it goes live, it is what will start giving you credit on the MRR and
going flowing into the specializations and the tier progression metrics as well.
One key thing to call out, even if the registration becomes optional when you know the AE, many of
you have lived this multiple cases, for programs such as Velocity, which is our activated logo
benefit, the lead registration is actually the kickstart of the process. So even though it becomes
optional in order to participate in some of the rebate programs such as Velocity, and I think it's
the main one we have, you do need to register the opportunity regardless so that it kicks
start the process and you get to the payout part portion of that.
The key thing here, the use case is what gives us credit.
In the deep dive, I'll let you know where to see the use cases
that had been created.
The task here would be,
if you don't see a use case you're working on,
you want to have a discussion with the aid, okay?
Let's go to the next slide.
One of the most common points of confusion in the program
are how the use cases get credited.
So we already know that the use case is the key thing.
We have two types of use cases.
One is the influence use case,
and the other one is the source use case.
So first, the sourcing distinction.
The use case is sourced when you, the partner,
initiates the use case before the account team is involved.
So you're bringing us something new
and sourcing it to Databricks.
It is influenced when you join a use case
in the account team is already working on it.
That's the difference between the left and the right
up to the top.
So if you built up the slide, Joseb,
what we're tracking on the metric side for implementation,
for tier progression are sourced and implemented, okay?
So implemented down in the bar simply means
that you're doing the Hanson keyboard implementation work,
okay?
Now here's the part that I really want to land
because this is the correction
from how people often think about it.
You get credited for all implemented work,
regardless whether if it's sourced or influenced.
Sourcing and implementing are rewarded separately.
So, walking through these three scenarios,
if a use case is both sourced and implemented,
it counts in both buckets.
You see that we have a bucket for implemented
and a bucket for sourcing.
You get the credit twice, as Brandon was saying,
you can kind of double dip across the metrics.
Once for sourcing and once for implementing.
If you sourced it, but didn't implemented,
it is still counts in the source bucket.
And if it was influenced,
meaning the accounting was already there,
but you implemented it,
that counts too in the implemented bucket.
So hope the examples helped a little bit.
I'll pause here for questions, just in case,
to make sure that it's clear.
And if not, we can move along to double clicking
on the actual scoring.
Now that we cleared up those key terms.
Yeah, we have a couple.
I think that Brandon is typing an answer,
but maybe you can speak to this, Vanessa.
So, how are extensions of existing use cases handled?
So let's say the use case was registered a while ago,
it went live, and then the partner wants to register
an extension of that existing use case.
Go ahead, Brandon.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I can speak to that.
So there's two ways to approach this, right?
The easiest way and the fastest way to take control
on any use case that you're driving,
especially if you're doing it proactively,
is to register as a new use case.
One that lets you qualify the outcome,
how you're involved in the MRR.
Essentially, our deal registration form
is set at a U2 level, right?
Which meaning it's scoped and it's qualified.
That is the easiest way, if you're initiating something,
to drive that through.
Now, if it's a true extension,
and it's not being seen as a different use case,
it's important that you collaborate with the account team.
Now, the account team actually has the discretion
to break up use cases into multiple use cases.
And sometimes extensions are better suited
to be multiple use cases, which again, is why,
if it's something that you're initiating and driving,
it might make sense to put that in as a deal registration
or to have that conversation directly
with the account executive.
Thank you for that.
Very good.
I think that we don't have any other questions
pertaining to this topic, so you can carry on, Vanessa.
Wonderful.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So the next slide, it's a double click
on the metrics of the partner value score
with the thresholds.
So I'll start, you can see that to the left,
we have the three big metrics
that Brandon covered at a high level.
So now we're gonna deep dive into the metrics
and the thresholds.
So it's starting with the customer impact,
which is the first pillar.
This is all about consumption,
how you're influencing consumption
and the presence that you have on our joint customers.
So there are key three things
that we're providing points for in this section,
which are implemented MRR,
which as I mentioned is when you do the hands-on keyboard
work, regardless if you source or influenced,
unique customers, which is the joint customers
that you have implemented for throughout the year
or source for throughout the year.
And then source is when you initiate the use case
and the Databricks team was not involved yet.
Okay.
So it started with the first one,
implemented MRR here for every 20K,
you accumulate one point.
And we have a maximum of 20 points available
for this subcategory.
Okay.
So it's very important to say, just one step back,
one of the changes we did this beginning of the year
was that every February 1st,
which is when our fiscal year starts,
this particular pillar resets to zero.
So all of the partners will start with zero
partner values score points in the customer impact pillar.
And this aligns to how we actually work internally
with our sales teams,
where we have new goals every year and every half.
So what we're doing is that you will start to see
how your partner values score points
to start to increase gradually as your use cases
start to go live,
meaning your handsome key words face completes finishes
after February 1st, meaning within our fiscal year.
So every year you're going to see this,
this pillar resetting to zero
and it will start to increase as your use cases go live.
So you might have noticed that,
you might have seen a difference
between the DVUs that you had before February 1st
and you were visible to you
from the ones that are visible today
and that's the reason why.
Now we give you the full view
of the partner values score points
that you accumulate after February 1st.
So perfect, with the next one, you need customers.
This means customers for whom you have implemented
solutions after February 1st that already went live as well.
So we will count that as one unique customer
and of course the associated MRR to it,
it's going to be influencing the other two,
the other two buckets.
Here for every three unique customers,
you accumulate one point
and we have a maximum of 10 points for this subcategory.
The next subcategory is sourced MRR.
We already covered the concept of it,
but as a quick recap is when you initiate the use case
and the account team was not involved in the conversations,
one was not aware of the opportunity
and you pretty much bring data bricks into the use case.
So here for every 5K, you accumulate one point.
Okay, we have a maximum of 15 points available
for this subcategory.
All of this you can see from your analytics dashboard
when I will go there in a moment.
You can actually see what you're being taught
as implemented, sourced, influenced and so on.
So we give you visibility,
so you have a good management and control
of your partner value score points.
Okay, so the next section,
you let me know Jose if at some point I need to stop.
Happy to do that.
Just a clarification and good catch.
There's a typo under the GTM in brackets.
It should be 10 points instead of 45,
but yes, so just to reiterate customer impact 45,
readiness and enablement 45 and then GTM 10 points.
Yes, good catch.
Good catch, thank you.
Very important clarification.
We need to make sure we update that before uploading.
Okay, awesome, perfect.
So readiness and enablement,
this is also 45 points at some maximum.
We have two subcategories.
One is the technical certified unique individuals.
To clarify there, here we're tracking
amount of unique certified individuals.
So think about those that had obtained
their first certification at a minimum,
we will count them as one individual.
If we have an individual who obtains
more than one certification,
that individual will continue to count as one individual
because we're counting amount of individuals,
not necessarily amount of certifications.
So that differentiation is important here.
And for every two certified individuals,
you accumulate one point
and we have a maximum of 30 points available
in this subcategory out of the 45, okay?
So the next one is active badges.
These are the badges that you can obtain
in Partner Academy in a click through experience,
totally for free.
They span from 14 minutes to 1.5 hours approximately.
We have an offer for the various roles,
sales, technical leadership, pre-sales, delivery.
We have over 35 plus, I would say,
from 35 to 40 badges that will qualify.
Any badge in the Partner Academy will qualify for this.
Every four badges gives you one point
and you have a maximum of 15 points to accumulate
in this subcategory out of the 45.
One key thing, frequently asked questions
is that the difference between a certification and a badge.
So I already explained what a badge is, right?
Just going back to the certification.
for a moment. The certification is are the industry recognized certifications where you do have a
proctored exam. It's highly technical. We have two types associated professional. That's the
certification and professional and associate will be the same for us in the partner program.
So if someone, if you have two individuals obtaining associate level, they will accumulate
one point. If you have two individuals obtaining professional level, you will accumulate one
point. Okay. The next section is the go to market section, correct, 10 points, not 45 as it says on
the screen. Here we have two ways to accumulate. Right now we're focusing on one as we prep internally
to recognize the customer satisfaction survey. We're establishing that and once ready,
it's going to be included in a more active way across and throughout our programs. For now,
the recommendation is that you submit two success stories. Each success story will give you five
points. So for two success stories, you will be maxing out the 10 points available in this
in this pillar. Frequently asked questions here. They do not need to be an implementation from
this year. It can be a previous implementation, but you need to submit it this year. Okay. Meaning
after February 1st, so you can accrue the 10 points meaning if you submitted customer success
stories before February 1st, those won't be counting or carrying on to this year. We will
continue to ask fresh customer success stories each year, which means that this this pillar also
resets to zero. So the only pillar that does not reset to zero is not subject to that rule,
is the capacity and capability, the one for certifications and badges. Here, this is tied
to the validity of your certifications and the badges. They have a two year validity
timeframe. So as long as you keep your certified individuals valid and the badges are still active,
they will still count. Okay, I'll pause there before moving on to the demo of the analytic
dashboard. Okay. If we don't have questions, I think we can move on.
Brandon is typing furiously. I think that he has answered most of the questions.
Okay. So Ali has a question regarding customer success stories. Do the customer stories have
to be public references? No, today they do not. But I would say if you do give us a public story,
we'll be able to do that and share that more internally, which will benefit you, right?
Obviously, if it's anonymous, you'll still get the credit for it, but it limits what we can do as far
as promoting you on that story. Yeah. Thank you for that. So that's in terms of whether you have
the permission of disclosing the name of the account or not, right? So 100% aligned with what
Brandon said. On the other hand, we do need to require to be publicly published anywhere, right,
in your website or blog, or even if it's kind of an anonymous success story, but we do require
it to be publicly published. So we will ask for a link on the form. The other thing is that when
you're submitting, you might be asked for the name of the customer. This does not mean that we're
going to be disclosing or doing any sort of marketing effort around it. So just FYI, when
you're completing the form, it's totally under NDA if it's an anonymous customer success story.
That's another common question we get. Okay. Yeah. So just for clarification in terms of
the weightage for each of these success stories, so it's up to five points each if the logo is
public up to two points if it's anonymized. So you can max out at 10 points with two public
logos or with five public logos, right? So that's how you can combine them. Or you can do a combination
of CSAT, a customer satisfaction survey, plus a success story, for example. That's another way of
getting those 10 points in the GTM. And then there's one question around,
are there examples of how to word the success stories and where do they live?
So the answer to this is yes, there are great examples and they're available on our dot com. So
if you go to databricks.com, you will find lots of success stories that are publicly available to
anyone. That gives you an idea of the language that we use. Those are reviewed by our branding team,
by our marketing teams as well. And then you can also follow some of our other partners in
the ecosystem. They constantly publish stories on their LinkedIn pages. Those have been reviewed
many times. So if you see that they're tagging us or tagging different teams across data bricks,
you will find some good examples there. My recommendation though is to make sure that you
also download the marketing guides that are available on the partner portal and that you also
align the language to the industry outcome maps so that it's very tangible. What was the impact
of your intervention or your implementation in terms of customer outcomes? So the industry
outcome maps are your best friends also in terms of how to frame the story in a compelling way.
All right. Thank you for that Jose. Awesome. Let me know. Do we have more questions?
Do we jump to the analytics dashboard and chair my screen? I think just real quick,
I'll jump on a couple of these. So I think the first one was, and it's come up,
that we had dashboard data that was stale. So you've probably seen that note in there.
That is being addressed this week. I think we actually updated that earlier this week,
but we're doing some just final tests on it so that we can get that back in sync.
But if you were looking at that and you saw that note previously, we were about a month delayed
in doing a data sync on some of the data points in there. So again, coming in on Monday,
check again. That should be cleared. Yeah. Okay. Let's carry on. I'm just going to go through a
couple of these real quick. Go ahead. This is the other one we're here for. So yeah. So today,
we do not have an export data capability from the PBS dashboard. We've taken that in as feedback.
We're just working with our compliance team on that, but there is no functionality. So if you're
looking for it in there, it's not available. I think the other one we had is what is the lifespan
of these points? So this works on our fiscal year. So you'll have all these points for a year
until it carries, until you, sorry, it cuts over to the next year where you essentially start again.
So again, everything you're earning in this program, we look and measure this at an annual level.
Yeah. The capacity and capability points, which are your unique certified individuals and badges,
will carry on as long as they're still active. So those points will probably be there at the
beginning of the year. If they're still active, even, you know, the customer impact pillar will
reset and the go to market pillar will reset to zero. But the readiness and enablement points,
as long as everyone is active, that you will see them carry over in your dashboard.
And we do that February 1st. Awesome. Great. Okay. All right. Any other questions? Okay.
Good. So I'll go to sharing for the analytics dashboard deep dive. So hopefully you have yours
up so you can follow along. I think I saw some of the new partners on the last NPO. So hopefully
you had the time to get to the 10 points through badges and are able to see the analytics dashboard.
Okay, let me go to sharing. I think I sent a request to share. Who say? Yeah, I allowed it,
but seems like there was an issue. Can you try again? Sure. There you go. Awesome. Thank you.
Wow. I'll hide this. Awesome. So this is the landing page of the partner portal. The way you
navigate to the analytics dashboard, it's on there more. If you've been recently navigating,
you probably do a lot on the sales deal dashboard where you can see the lead registrations that
you and your team have submitted. If you are the admin, you can actually see what everyone has
submitted. If you're not the admin, you only see your submissions of lit registrations.
As I mentioned, lit registration opens the door to co-selling with us. And then as the
opportunity is validated by DAE as an opportunity that will start generating consumption, it will
be converted into a use case by the accounting, which is what all
ultimately gives you the credit.
So that's why you want to always be on top of
the analytics dashboard over here
and work with your use cases.
So the use case dashboard leaves,
second, personally, send it, minimize,
leaves in this section of the analytics dashboard
that is called use case.
We're going to get there in a moment, right?
Because as I said, this is what really drives
recognition of the customer impact pillar.
You need customers, MRR, sourcing, implementation.
Before that, I would like to give you a quick view
into your high level partner value score,
the breakdown on the metrics so you can see where you are.
So a little bit on how to read this.
So in this graphic, you're going to have
the current partner value score your company has
as a high level.
You know that our range goes from one to 100.
In order to progress based on the geo
with the table that Brandon showed before,
you know what your target is for to progression
or to maintain your current tier.
Okay, here where it says assigned tier,
you can see the current tier you have for this year.
It means that you're going to hold that tier
because we do D motions all the way
until the beginning of next year.
So if you get promoted in August,
you will see this changing.
If you don't get promoted in August,
you will maintain this current tier
that you see in this field all the way until January 31st
when we do all the calculations again
for promotions and D motions.
But that's, are you sharing your screen?
I am.
Okay, so it's not been up, I think for the dashboard.
Here.
There you go, perfect.
Yeah, we can see that now.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you for letting me know.
Okay, so again, in this part,
this graph is where you see your current
high level partner values score points of the company,
you know, from one to 100,
this is the high level points that will be used
for progression, right?
Or the motion, okay?
So in this section here where it says assigned tier,
you see the current tier that you have for the year
unless you get promoted.
D motions are going to happen in January 31st, right?
So you have this tier all the way until January 31st
unless you get promoted, okay?
Now, here we give you an example of, okay,
looking at the current numbers where you are,
what is the tier that you most likely will have
in the next round?
If you say assist, right?
So here's giving you a sneak peek on, okay,
this is your current one,
but this is the prediction of the next tier
looking at the numbers that you already have.
So for example, you might be a silver partner
throughout the entire year
because you obtained that in the past.
And maybe you have been doing a lot of work
and you might see gold here
and pretty much predicting, okay, maybe in the next round,
you're kind of getting there
in terms of partner values score points.
It gives you a little bit of visibility
on your partner values score points
and how you're tracking against the various tiers up and down,
okay?
So here we give you two ways of looking at the breakdown
of the partner value score
of this overall partner value score
because we know we have three pillars
that add up to the overall partner values score points, right?
So we give you two ways.
One is the bar view and the other one is the table view.
So the bar view, you have in orange
the amount of maximum points
that you can accumulate per category, right?
And then you can see in the blueish one,
where you are today and what you have obtained
out of the total available points, okay?
This is your bar view, very simple.
And here is a table view
that might be a little bit more like on point
because you will actually see out of each subcategory
the amount that you have obtained,
the translation of that to points
out of the maximum points, okay?
So maybe you have, and I will, you know,
please carry on with me and use your imagination.
Maybe you have implemented 20K MRR,
which will give you one point based on the table
that we saw before out of the 20 that are available,
for example.
So here you will be able to see the amount
of implemented MRR you have,
uni customers you have, source MRR you have,
and how many points that translates to, okay?
Same for the capacity and capability one.
In the table view, you will see the amount
of certified individuals,
the amount of points that translates to
and will give you a visibility of your goal,
like the maximum amount of points
that you have available to max out that subcategory.
Same for active badges and the success of stories same.
Actually, in this example here, you can see, okay,
you have two success stories,
which equates to 10 partner values core points out of 10.
So this is kind of the view on the high level
for your full analytic dashboard partner values core breakdown,
okay?
So besides that, we have various segments
within the analytic dashboard,
because we're focusing today on proper recognition
for partner program.
It's all about use cases and also the enablement part, okay?
So I want to dive into the enablement
analytic dashboard component today.
I will show you a little bit.
So for example, in the enablement,
if you click on see more,
then I'll have a lot of data on this test account,
but you do have down here a way to search
by training category.
So we should say technical certified,
you can click there, select,
and we'll give you a list of the ones
that are technically certified for you.
If they have opted in for us to show their PII,
you will see them.
If not, you will probably see a dash or something.
So you can kind of see, you know,
who is certified already in your company.
You can start working with that.
Another option that you will see here,
that we don't see it because it's a test account,
are the active badges.
You can also filter by that
and you can see who has obtained badges already.
Those are kind of the two main things
that are the enablement side can help you.
Now, we know that in order to progress,
you need delivery experts.
We're working on having the delivery experts visible
on the dashboard, they're not visible today.
So for anything that is related to training,
maybe your internal records are not matching up
your capacity and capability numbers here.
We do have a ticket that you can open.
They can actually do some health check for you
and start having a conversation with you
about those discrepancies and helping you,
giving you visibility into the delivery experts
you already have, giving you visibility
and an export of the technical certified individuals
for those who have opted in.
And they can start working with you
on any discrepancy you might see.
The badges tend to be not an issue
because they get auto recognized on our partner academy,
but sometimes with certified individuals
considering that a lot of people take the proctored exam
using their own personal email for portability.
We do have some scenarios there
where we need a collaboration with you,
given a visibility on who had obtained certifications
that we might not be seeing, right?
We need that information in order to recognize it.
So maybe, Jose, I don't know if you can help me
with the link to open the ticket on the enablement side
so that the partners can have a conversation
with the enablement team and start making sure
that everything that there's-
I put it in the chat.
Awesome, awesome.
So now going on the customer impact pillar
recognition best practices, same,
I'm in the landing page still, so you can see.
Now I'm going to the use case section
and I'm going to click on see more.
Okay, one piece of recommendation here,
it will auto default to customer fiscal year,
meaning it's going to show you the use cases
that were created by the account team after February 1st.
Okay, we know that the sell cycle can span,
you know, from a few weeks to a couple of months,
sometimes even years.
So my recommendation is so that you can see everything
regardless of when it was created.
You go and select all time and hit on apply.
If you don't hit on apply, it will remain in fiscal year.
You might be thinking it filtered,
but no, you need to hit on apply.
And now I'm able to see all of the use cases
that had been created regardless of the creation date.
Mm-hmm, and now I have a visibility
into the stage column, meaning which ones are still not live
and which ones are already live.
So our stages go from one to six,
you can see that you have the use case stage two,
for example, for us that is scoping, right?
And we have all the way, the sell cycle,
all the way to wrapping up your hands on keyboard face,
which is the implementation.
That's when the A will move it to live.
and the recognition will start.
Okay?
So first, as I mentioned,
the lead registration becomes optional.
So one thing that as an alliance person
or in charge of making sure
that the recognition is happening properly,
one key thing you want to do is regardless
if you see the lead on the deal dashboard
that we saw outside of this,
the most important thing is that you see everything
that you're working on in a line item in this dashboard.
You need to see it on the use case dashboard.
As long as you see it here listed,
it means that you're set up for proper recognition.
And it's just a matter of a few key points
that I'm going to work you through for best practices.
And once the AI moves it to live,
you know that the recognition will kick in.
Okay?
First thing, make sure everything you're working on
is listed here.
This is what you need to know.
If you don't see it here,
as I mentioned, the AI helps you create the use case.
So it's a conversation with the AI.
If you already are talking to the AI,
you can simply say,
can you create the use case for me?
This is what provides us credit on the partner program.
And so one, very good conversation to have.
They are not compensated by use cases.
They use use cases to project sales, right?
So again, perfectly good conversation to have.
Most of them are aware that use case
is how you get recognized,
but you might find some that might not know.
So again, perfectly conversation to have, right?
So let's say that we have the use case here, wonderful.
Okay, that's one key thing to be in the look out.
Now, as I mentioned,
we give you partner values core points
for two types of use cases.
Okay?
The use case is here.
Now I want to see,
am I properly set up to influence the right buckets?
Okay, that is implementation.
Everything that you implement should count,
regardless if you source it or influence it.
And then we give you extra points for sourcing, right?
So we give you visibility into that
also in this same dashboard.
So we have the implementation column.
What you want to do is make sure that you're properly tagged
as the implementation partner
if you're doing the handsome keyboard work, okay?
For example, here in line four,
I have a non-roll,
like if you're not tagged as the implementation partner.
In this case,
it could be that the customer is doing
the self-implementation
or professional services to do an implementation
or something else.
So in this case,
it's not going to influence the implementation bucket.
So if you're doing the implementation,
you want to make sure that you're tagged as the implementation.
This is manually done by DAE
because they're the ones close to the opportunity
and how things are being developed.
So again, perfectly good conversation to have.
This does not impact the DAE whatsoever.
Definitely, especially before going live,
you want to make sure you've come into your use case dashboard
and check on these columns that you're properly tagged
and that you agree with the current tagging
for each of the use cases, okay?
So that's the implementation.
And then the Cosell column tells you
if the DAE is tagging you as sourcing it to Databricks
or Influencing, meaning helping a segment consumption
and you have a role, but you didn't source it, right?
So you also want to make sure you agree
with the way you're being tagged here.
Same thing, this does not affect the DAE's compensation,
whether it's your sourcing or influencing,
perfectly good conversation to have as well, okay?
Now, I know it's not the topic of today's call,
but I wanted to take the opportunity,
if you're pursuing a specializations,
this is how you know that,
made you may know that one of the requirements is
the annual recurrent revenue consuming
of at least three joint customers
for the product specializations.
Just to point out, this is how we track that, right?
So the MRR of each use case will be associated
to the products, the DAE tags here.
Again, same thing, if a product might be missing,
talk to the DAE so that we're recognizing the MRR
all on the right buckets 100% all of the time, okay?
So that's that.
Do we have questions?
Because I think those were kind of the key things
that I wanted to call out.
I think that Brandon has answered most of them,
but there's one around use cases.
Brandon, do you want to come up mute
and just answer Nicholas's question?
Yeah, so the question is, how do we define a use case?
Is it better to have more use cases with less MRR
or less use cases with more MRR?
I think this, first off, it's important to know
that the way that we've set up use cases,
our account executives at Databricks have a lot of autonomy
because what you're seeing here is pulled directly
from their CRM, right?
So again, you can influence that through registrations
that go through and get approved or via collaboration, right?
But ultimately that number you see in there is dictated
by the AE or the SA on that account within Databricks.
So definitely collaborate wherever possible.
Now the question is, it's gonna come down to
what makes the most sense and what is most efficient, right?
I have seen some large use cases that might span
a three year rollout that then breaks off
into multiple smaller use cases as it starts
to deploy, again, for efficiency purposes.
Sometimes that requires a conversation with the account team
on how to strategically set that up based on the customer needs.
What I would say is most use cases that AEs
will view, take on board, it's typically measured
at around that $5,000 MRR mark.
So I think 60K ARR.
So again, what you're probably not gonna wanna do
is put in a whole bunch of use cases
that are less than $5,000 and MRR,
if they are truly packed together,
it makes more sense to put that together
and to get that above that 5K mark.
It just makes it more efficient.
All right.
Yeah.
And then Rafaul has another question.
I think I can take this one.
So how did you recognize who is the AE for the use case?
So the way this works, Rafaul,
is you will register the deal using the deal registration
form and then there will be an SDR
who will be working with you
and facilitating that introduction
to the account executive.
So the SDR will be qualifying the lead that you submitted
and then facilitating that warm introduction
between you and the sales team.
Typically there's other individuals involved
at the account level also.
So you may have an AE and solutions architect, for example.
So they will facilitate that introduction with you.
So you don't need to figure this out.
Once the deal registration is converted into a use case,
then it will become available in the use case view
for the analytics dashboard.
You go to the analytics dashboard,
you click on use cases, you click on similar,
and you will see what Vanessa is showing here.
It will show you who the account owner
is at the use case level.
And you will have additional details
like who is the partner sales manager
because we are verticalized.
So you will be able to see who's the right partner counterpart
in the use case level.
So all of that information will appear
in the use case dashboard
that you're seeing right now on the screen.
Yeah, pretty much this account owner,
it's the account executive, is the AE.
Correct.
The main for the customer.
Yes, awesome.
By the way, the stages are also progressed by the AE
because they're close to how the sales cycle is progressing.
That's another frequently asked question.
So that's also important.
Awesome.
So that's it.
Do we have any other questions regarding the dashboard?
Because that's all I had.
There's one about crediting 10 points.
I'll let you take that one.
I don't know.
Can you read the question for me?
It says, last week during the partner onboarding webinar
series session, there was a big campaign call
to join this today, and we will credit them with 10 points.
Oh, no, no, no.
So just to clarify, the call to action
was if you have not, if you don't have access
to the analytics dashboard, that you can obtain
your first part, 10 partner values, core points.
The suggestion was completing sales badges,
then email partner up so that you can get access
to your analytics dashboard and can follow along
in this session.
So I'll just say further confusion,
but the ask was to obtain the 10 partner values core points
required to get access to the analytics dashboard
via completing 40 sales badges.
Hope that clarifies.
OK, anything else?
If not, I think we're wrapping up,
and we're going to update the slide
and then upload it into the PDC office hours and the recording
as well.
Let me see.
Do it.
Yeah.
We do have one additional question regarding certifications from Kendra.
So what does the train not certified mean?
Yeah, that's a great question Kendra.
Looking at the Q&A.
So yeah, you're probably looking at the enablement part,
which is great love to see that you're exploring.
Yeah, what that means is again,
not much data on the enablement site.
So for that, but follow along, I'll walk you through it.
So what that means is that we're giving you
a visibility on who in your company had taken courses
that are aligned as preparation to a certification,
but they have not taken the step of testing.
So for partner values core, we look at certified individuals.
So we're giving you visibility on your pipeline
and who could be ready to add up to those points.
So it's kind of a low hanging fruit on your side
to target those individuals and say,
hey, you're really close.
You're ready to the course you prepped.
Let's talk about when you can take the exam
that will actually add up to the partner values core points.
Okay.
I think that's all.
Yeah.
There's just two more open questions.
If you don't mind, I think one with Nicholas and one with Wendy.
If you can just add more context in there,
because I think I'm missing the first half of the questions,
but I can answer those offline.
Yeah.
I think Nicholas, your question is about the customer success stories.
So do they need to be separate different customers
or can they submit to success stories for the same customer
and still earn the same 10 points?
It is use case based, so it can be the same customer
as long as it's a different use case.
We'll be happy to proceed those and provide points.
Okay.
Yes, does that happen upon completion?
Is that low?
Okay.
Wendy, I think your question has to do with how we do promotions.
Right?
So you were asking at what point
you will be able to get promoted to the next tier.
So as we mentioned, there's one mid-year review
where we do only promotions and that's at the end of July.
So all the metrics for the current fiscal year
will help you get to that milestone
if you have met both the partner value score
and the qualification gates of the delivery experts
and champions by the deadline of July 31st.
But if you don't make that first mid-year review,
you still have another opportunity to get promoted
by the end of fiscal year on January 31st.
So all of the metrics for your current fiscal year
will continue to accrue all the way up to January 31st.
So you have some runway seal from here to January 31st
to complete those qualification gates
and to reach the minimum thresholds for promotion.
I hope that clarifies your question.
Yeah.
Good.
I'll answer Kendra's.
So it says, for customer success stories,
I haven't approved a story that just got approved,
but it is from a previous fiscal year.
Is that why he's not reflecting the partner value score points?
Thank you for the question, Kendra,
because this could be happening for various partners.
So the use case can be a story of an implementation
that was done before the fiscal year.
That's totally fine.
You're just submitting it this year and it just got approved.
So it should be counting within this fiscal year
for the partner value score points,
like the go-to-market pillar for these year's points.
Okay?
So the reason why you might not be seeing it,
it's because we're kind of in the process
of updating the dashboard.
So that's what Brandon mentioned.
The team is aiming to do by the end of the week.
We've been working on it for a few times.
Apologies to everyone for that.
If you want to see the updated numbers as we fix this,
as we work through this,
you can email partnerops at databricks.com
and they can give you kind of a fresher look
into your numbers on the partner values score points.
Okay.
Yeah, and I'm going to take one from Pratam regarding CSAT.
I'm going to put in the Q&A, the email address
that you can use.
One caveat though, when you email that email address,
please do not copy partners at or partnerops.
There are some routing issues that can happen
if you copy more than one shared inbox
when you send that email.
So please just email that email address
that I'm going to share with you in the Q&A.
I'm going to put it in the chat as well
so that they can trigger the CSAT process for you.
Okay?
So I think there were some questions regarding the
relaxed requirements.
So sorry about that.
These are the current requirements to move up
to the tiers remaining in your current tier.
So this is the partner values score required per geo.
And these are the additional requirements.
So delivery experts and champions.
So we didn't dive into the process for these two.
However, we do a previous recording
on the PDC office hours landing page
where you will see very clearly you can hit a replay.
We covered delivery expert champions
and actually a specializations,
even though specializations are not tied to tier progression,
but it'll be great that you can start looking at those.
We explain that the process for delivery experts,
we explain what they are
and we explain the same thing for champions.
At a really high level, delivery expert is the next step
after completing any data break certification
to focus on one particular product.
So we have an offer of courses there.
And again, they are in the academy,
they're totally for free.
DXM is hands-on, but it's also in the academy.
It's not a proctored experience
like our industry recognized certifications.
So in the champions,
you do want to think about your highest technical profile,
those individuals who you align
to the most complex projects
that are your champions internally for Databricks.
Those are the ones
that you want to put forward for nomination.
You can email partners at Databricks.com.
They will share the nomination requirements with you.
So very high level key things that they need to have
is there a lot of hands-on experience.
They will undergo a selection process
that includes an interview.
And you will be required to say which use cases
they have led on the technical side as the technical experts
leading the project.
We used to have specializations here.
So that's why Brandon was referring to
so we relaxed the requirements as well.
And accelerators, we used to have accelerators as well
at the beginning of the year.
Yep, and I can just touch on that just real quickly.
Part of the reason for doing that was
we wanted to enable partners who are bronze
who already have a go-to-market capability.
Again, that bronze tier really being a point in time.
We wanted to give them a better chance to differentiate
based on the specializations available
because we do plan to push more of those
into especially some of the emerging regions and markets.
So what happened is we actually decided to pull off
that specialization requirement from the program
to make it more accessible.
We also pulled the blogs, right?
So again, it made it easier to attain silver and then gold,
but also it's a nod to say everybody on this call
should also be looking at how can I pursue
specializations going forward to start to differentiate
right out the gate rather than a tier-based approach
being the end game.
All right, thank you.
Awesome.
Yes, the champions and the delivery experts
could be the same person, correct.
Awesome.
I think this is great.
I mean, thank you everyone for all the questions.
There's been very interactive, very valuable questions
and it's a pleasure for us to host you as always.
We invite you to join us into the PDC office hours
coming towards the end of the month.
We're going to cover key things and key opportunities
after all of the announcements and data and AI summit.
So don't miss that one.
It's coming up in the next couple of weeks.
So if you haven't seen it,
the PDC office hours landing page
is on the Get Started tab in the partner portal.
Join us every month.
This is the main webinar where we really walk you
throughout and accompany you on your Databricks matured.
journey. So thank you again for joining us and see you in the next one. Bye. Thank you. Bye.